do you ever kind of because I saw uh Lil
G just got sentenced to some serious
prison time
um and we think kind of like
everybody kind of went their own way
when it came to the group it feels like
you're kind of the one guy who's kind of
cut through and like been able to really
be consistent and really kind of show
improve as a solo artist
um a shout out to Young Teo he's up you
know he's obviously has some dope solo
[__] too but for you like uh
not knowing your personal relationship
with these guys anymore but do you tap
in with somebody like Lil G if he you
know gets he has to go sit down for 20
years like just on somebody like you
said some brothership or is that
relationship kind of a rap
slimming my brother
and that's it it's let me my brother
that's fair who's gonna be on the EP
uh [__] really just Kaylin for real for
real for real I can't wait to hear that
you know Mama's you know I'm trying to
push that I'm trying to push that one uh
I'm trying to push that one sound man
I'm trying to gain my my lady fan base
you found me so he's on the hook uh yeah
for sure yes sir was there something you
guys got in the studio together on yeah
yep I called that [__] that [__]
pulled up laid that [__] down lay my
[__] down boom classic it's one of the
months too on my mama yo speak to me
because uh Mac Dre is from Vallejo and
obviously you know one of the more
celebrated artists to come out of the
bay especially if you're from the bay
did you go up listening to Mac Dre were
you or was he I mean that was kind of
like past your generation a bit like was
that something that you just kind of had
to go back
his music was always around like of
course like [__] knew like all the all
the big [__] like even like even like
the big the songs that was like big in
the streets like [__] knew mostly of
them like most of that [__] though like
I really had to go back and go you feel
me dig do my own little researching for
real when I was young like I was really
into [__] like
like I was really into like the
mainstream [__] like Lil Wayne Like of
course a young [__] at that time like
Soulja Boy like I had to really do my
own digging I knew the main [__] though
but like to hear him on his gangster
[__] like when he first came out I was
like early [__] yeah yeah I had to go do
my own research for sure I do feel like
you guys kind of influenced a generation
of I feel like
SOB y'all probably don't get as a group
the credit you deserve in terms of you
guys influenced a lot of La guys
so I feel like a lot of like how you
guys are rapping the flow y'all had like
kind of the slightly offbeat [__] like I
feel like you guys kind of and this can
be said about the Bay Area in general
with a lot of [__] that happens
you guys influence a lot of [__] but
don't necessarily get the credit for the
influence that you guys have on hip-hop
even La hip-hop do you guys did you guys
notice that like happening because you
guys are the hottest [__] moving and a
lot of people in La started to pop up
that in my opinion sounded a lot like
what you guys are doing yeah did you
notice that yeah for so you know how
that [__] go like
we don't really you know how that [__]
go like we don't really get no we don't
get credit for a lot of [__] but you
feel me like [__] not gonna hit the
scene cry about it and pout for real I
mean like it is what it is at the end of
the day though a lot of [__] that you
feel me a lot of [__] I run into like
they're paying [__] homage like when
they see a [__] but like [__] probably
not just gonna Ain't Nobody's Gonna
Wanna put it out there like oh [__] I
ain't gonna lie
I'll relieve like [__] really base my
flaw off the young [__] like we young
[__] like maybe if we was like
some OG's or something in the game like
[__] it'd be easier to pay
homage to be like oh I really been grew
up listening young [__] you feel me
don't nobody not too many [__]
want to give a young [__] too much
credit you feel me I think a young [__]
big-headed oh they don't want to give a
a young [__] that much juice that much
power but [__] don't be you family
like I think it's beyond some humble
[__] [__] not really tripping off that
[__] like it is what it is like like I
think of you guys and I think of like
Shoreline Mafia had like a lot of
Sons like it is kind of yeah for so you
gotta remember like one [__]
might copy is and then the [__]
that copied us a [__] might have
copied them I didn't not even not listen
to our [__] starting me like it's just
it's just so much recycled [__] going on
you don't know who a [__] really
getting [__] from like we started a lot
of [__] but like a lot of [__] got
recycled like you feel me like
[__] get it's like lost files
like [__] don't know where they
got this and that from right it's all
good though like I'm glad to see that
[__] created a way for
everybody to eat for real cause a lot of
the young [__] scene was dead it wasn't
no young [__] really rapping for real
like we taught young [__] how to talk
[__] you feel me just be free you feel
me uh speaking mine it's a lot of
cappers up on this [__] too that you
feel they making no way though you feel
me congratulate them boys
feeding a lot of young [__] off the
way but a [__] started but I
ain't gonna say [__] we all
started this [__] as a group but right
you found me like they ain't tripping
out that [__] let them boys go crazy